a leader who does not get the talent no
matter where it comes from is not likely
to succeed talent exists beyond the ivy
school's talent exists in lower school's
talent exists in people who have never
gone to school whether you are a woman
whether you are in some other ethnicity
it's the talent we are to look into
so my first item is to look into raw
talent so we say there is talent in
diverse people age has nothing to do
with it
a nine year old can do the algorithmic
planning today from India so no
discrimination on age either you can be
young you can be very senior if you have
energy great now we ask the question why
these are not progressing fast enough
first I want to tell you about the balls
if you have hundred men not all the
hundred going to be on the balls there's
going to be a small percentage why
because there are certain
characteristics in these people that
make them good board members now there
could be some mistakes but the fact is
only a few of the hundred going to be in
divorce and they develop certain kind of
skills so I want to tell you what those
skills are and if you don't have those
skills you're not going to get there the
first and foremost a skill of a board
member is to be able to ask the right
questions most people don't know how to
ask the right questions number
is to be able to understand the
financial side of the business business
acumen is mandatory to be able to read
in a proper way the balance sheet the
P&L the competitions the trends
it's a specialist skill how to diagnose
them to the route if you don't have it
you're not gonna succeed vmon succeeded
at the board who have these skills and
they become chairpersons of the audit
committee they are in high demand this
is the route and then obviously you have
to have leadership skills and poise
doing that so we need to create these
training programs inside over time get
these people to run a profitable a
statement company product line country
as soon as possible and give them
coaching once they get to P&L and
succeed they will be eligible to move up
very fast we are not doing that
search for raw talent and train them
separately but on those items because
you have to work a little bit more to
find this talent that can be molded in
the men's that is going on for decades
but again it's going to be a very few
out of a lot of people who are going to
get there the talent is in shortage look
for the talent seek the talent and
develop the talent
[Music]